[Musique]
une vache à saint germain des prés un
fait divers à la une de france soir un
faits divers montés de toutes pièces
pour divertir pendant une matinée de
dimanche
les germanopratins 10h15 un camion venu
de normandie est piloté par
d'authentiqués paysans s'immobilise
place saint germain
manque de chance ils viennent de crever
mais il ya à l'intérieur du camion
une vache que julienne or pour préparer
il faut que julienne descendent du
véhicule où l'installer ce ne sont pas
les enclos qui manquent
place saint germain et lequel choisir
celui là et pourquoi pas une fait face
aux deux magots un endroit idéal pour
que saint germain des près de vienne
saint germain les champs
[Musique]
10h30 les imaginations s'échauffent déjà
la vache fait rêver les bouchers
localement non elle n'a pas l'air vilain
non dans le fond plus d'opérer de les
chercher à la campagne le ferez vous
3 que les gars sont partis d'eux pour
être embarquée à ses fans et des
cartouches on veut une fois bien puis
10h35 pour la première fois dans
l'histoire des deux magots le garçon
sert à boire un bovidé
je pense qu'un sous la dent les démagos
il est vrai que germain des prés et ans
consonance un peu agricole qu'est ce que
vous lui avez donné comme
pas de loto pour qu'est-ce que ça boit
une façon naturelle aux deux
au mans on partait si on donnait de
vittel ça coûterait bien cher 10h45
le gardien de l'enclos sans doute un
fêtard se réveille vêtu comme un
gotchaux il n'en a pas là mais s'en
prend à nos braves paysans et julienne
est mise au pilori arrière de cuzon
sérieux les non croyants normandie mais
c'est autre chose que ça les
qualifications à la viande dans les
bêtes dans tous ses passagers mais
qu'est ce que ça vous fait au moins
absolument rien ne serait pas sain que
politique
malgré tout on a l'impression d'être
dans un autre monde depuis deux matches
on partait en week-end comme ça voyez
moi je partais en normandie à ça mais
parce qu'il paraît que c'est très beau
la normale le temps faire
la tête de l tur pander rigueur c'est
une vache tu vois tu savais pas ce que
c'était
il faut qu'ils viennent à paris pour
voir des vaches toi ça jouera les vaches
une fois que vous savez ces procès par
les plus heureux en fait c'est une drôle
de vie ouais je retiens qu'on commençait
le donne du lait après bâle ii lorient
manger souvent comment je faisais de 500
euros barrière en achetant du cheval ce
thème de la vache je devrais les cochons
à les cochons
[Musique]
on veut l'adage est attendue
des pléiades lâche dans le monde mieux
c'est
ça distrait la population
mais ménagez pas me rabaisser ans
pourrait rester pour être des gens à
l'intérieu ely vall 2 et oui bien sûr
assis ici par exemple à beaubourg r ça
rappellera les kills de burelle avant la
guerre il y avait des vaches sur les
canapés
insensible à cette poésie les
cultivateurs réparé et julienne
s'impatiente
l'interviewer je vous répondrai
peut-être ans là bas ce qui est social
passe dans sa tête contre gotchaux il ne
décolère pas
11h10 un képi à l'horizon il comprend la
triste situation dans laquelle se
trouvent les agriculteurs même sens et
au moins
mais la patience du képi a ses limites
et à 11h20 le képi vers valley et cette
vache et vous avez l'air bien surpris
et vertement j'ai très bien surpris elle
vous regarde aussi ce nombre
actuellement non en raison d'un dos
bref vous regardez oui à quoi
penseriez-vous parce qu'on dit toujours
que les vaches c'est complètement idiot
je suis pas de votre avis quel est il
toujours avec la vache a quelque chose
de malin dans le lobe valladeres et
c'est exact
oui celle-là c'est dans le gauche
whitney julienne a regardé son oeil
gauche
exactement l'oeil gauche et un feu rouge
il était un peu il est plus intelligent
de l'oeil droit
exactement oui vif il est plus vif a oui
[Musique]
et c'est ainsi qu'à 11h40 en plein coeur
de paris dans le quartier des
intellectuels le mythe de la vache
idiote de nature a été détruit
l'intelligence de la vache est
maintenant reconnue mais il faut porter
la bonne nouvelle dans les provinces et
comme midi sonnent au clocher de saint
germain notre julienne reprend le chemin
de sa bétaillère et celui de sa norme
hante
c'était une farce qui a permis à la race
bovine de retrouver sa dignité
[Musique]